I think my cortisol was upside down low and it should have been high and vice-versal.
What does that mean?
What certainly means adrenal issues.
So can be because stress issues, so remember the adrenal glands, as well as the thyroid
gland, secrete based upon nervous system, input, and other hormone input.
So what hormones act on the adrenal glands, the pituitary, what is the nervous system
that acts on the adrenal glands, the autonomic nervous system.
So if you have perceived stress, if I didn't even be any real stress, it's just perceived
stress.
It's called worry.
It's another word for it.
You will stimulate adrenal hormone output.
So understand, stress hormones have a distinct purpose, a good purpose, a positive purpose.
You're walking down the street and somebody comes at you with a knife.
You want to have a healthy adrenal gland to stimulate stress hormones so you can be the
daylights out of that, or run away as fast as you can.
That's going to be a sympathetic stimulation, sympathetic nervous system is going to be
stimulated.
Your parasympathetic is going to be down-regulated and you're going to be able to fight
free or freeze or get out of that situation to protect yourself.
But when we have nobody chasing us, nobody trying to kill us, but we perceive that like
health issues or relationship issues, or we just tend to be high anxiety people person.
So we tend to just, you know, ruminate on these things.
Then we're stimulating our adrenals and we're just causing just a lot of adrenal dysfunction.
You can get these upside down curves.
Now, another issue in a person that has the tendency, let's say they go, well, that's
me.
I tend to worry about things and I tend to just overthink things and I'm just constantly
just rolling around in my head all the time.
And you also have to look at glutamate levels and so glutamate is different than glutamate.
Glutamate is a neurotransmitter that's an excitatory neurotransmitter and I'm pretty sure
I have several blog posts and videos on this because it does tie to multiple genetic factors.
You can have some genetic issues on your GSH genes and your GAD genes that if you have
defects on those, you convert glutamate in your diet, which is amino acid from, you know,
eating foods that have protein, you convert it to glutamate quite regularly faster than
other people do.
And that's why some people tend to be just nervous, Nellies, they tend to have more anxiety,
they tend to, you know, if they're medically oriented, they tend to be on anxiety medication.
Because they are obsessive compulsive individuals.
Now, glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter that is not bad in itself.
And in fact, people that they have discovered, people that have higher levels of glutamate
are more intelligent, they study more, they don't sleep quite as much because they're thinking
about things, they're inventors, they're creative people.
So it's not a bad thing necessarily to have too much glutamate.
But if you are then feeding that pathway excessively, which what is the worst form of glutamate
on your brain, is they can call it monosodium glutamate, right?
And that is just a horrible form of glutamate that actually fires so strongly in the brain
that it actually burns pathways out.
High correlation between obsessive compulsive disorder people and glutamate levels in the
brain.
And that's where that, you know, nothing will clear that out perfectly, but trying to
really limit any foods that have MSG is really, really important for those people.
Even things with additives, colorings, things can stimulate glutamate quite strongly.
Sometimes people think it's a dopamine issue, but it's really a glutamate issue, really
a big problem.
And then glutamate excitatory neurotransmitter fires the sympathetic fires the pituitary fires
the adrenal and it's this whole negative cycle.
That's what I talked about.
If this is cortisol, it's just a huge negative cycle that can burn out.
You really need to get a hold of it, you know, from a spiritual standpoint to do different
mental practices where you're just going to use more prayer and meditation can be extremely
helpful, getting outside and growing yourself can be extremely helpful to us.
Adaptogens would be the first go to as far as nutrition goes.